let's talk about the economy a little
bit Donald Trump loves to talk about the
stock market on days that the stock
market goes up sort of like today looks
like it's going to be but on days when
the stock market is down like last
Friday when the Dow Jones Industrial
Average was down 600 points Trump says
nothing about it sometimes on a down day
Trump will actually say you know I don't
really pay attention to the stock market
which is an obvious lie it's very
similar with GDP GDP is gross domestic
product it's another indicator that
Donald Trump has talked a lot about he's
predicted and promised 4% 5% even 6% GDP
growth those numbers were pretty crazy
to begin with and it's bearing out that
Crump can't meet them and it turns out
that fourth quarter GDP in 2019 went up
2.1 percent full year 2019 GDP was just
2.3 percent that's the lowest in three
years now at a systemic level we should
be asking questions like what does GDP
tell us about an economy and what
doesn't it tell us about an economy
there's a lot that GDP doesn't tell us
about the state of the economy what
other indicators are important to
understand how the economy is doing for
the average person just GDP doesn't tell
us in the same way that you know the
stock market level doesn't tell us you
need other indicators these are good
important questions but we also have to
talk about accountability and holding
politicians to what they say Trump has
been promising for years and the White
House has been predicting for years
including for 2019
higher GDP numbers they failed to get
them now we can go further one of the
defenses of the 2017 tax reform that
Trump and Republicans passed was it
might look like it'll cut revenue to the
government but it's going to be so
stimulative to the economy that GDP will
go up tax revenues will go up we're
gonna win hugely none of that happened
but the super-rich still got their tax
cuts which we knew they were going to
get for the most part Donald Trump
ignores bad GDP numbers and if you press
him he will do what he's done his whole
career he'll blame somebody else
he blames the Federal Reserve he says
you know the Federal Reserve helped
Obama hugely with low federal funds
interest rates they're not helping me
the reality is the Fed has kept rates
quite low the Fed has done some
decreases to the federal funds rate
Trump blaming the Fed is another way to
shift the blame to someone to anyone
else and by the way who's in charge of
the Fed it's the guy that donald trump
selected so then remember when we look
at GDP we also want to look at the
deficit and once again because Donald
Trump has put so much stock in the
deficit he said he was going to get us a
surplus the surplus would pay off the
national debt within eight years that's
a joke some of his followers fell for it
the federal budget deficit is actually
up more than 20 percent from 2018 to
2019 so if we want to step back from the
day-to-day politics one of the
relationships we want to look at is how
is GDP growth comparing to deficit
growth some so-called deficit hawks
always say if the deficit is up it's bad
they don't say it when a Republican is
president but that's okay what they say
it basically at all other times the
reality though is if you want to have a
more sort of nuanced understanding of
deficit you want to look at how deficit
is changing in relation to GDP they
don't tend to care about that when it's
a Democratic president deficit bad when
it's a Republican president we don't
talk about deficit deficit up that's bad
debt up that's bad unless it's a
Republican president in which we in case
we only talk about GDP numbers or
whatever so let me give you the
non-political analysis okay I'm ignoring
party I don't care about party I'm
giving you a political and a
non-political economic analysis as far
as GDP growth goes two point three is
really not bad okay just because Trump
predicted more doesn't mean two point
three percent GDP growth is bad
I would prefer two point three instead
of these boom bust cycles that are
endemic to the type of economy that we
have two point three is not bad the real
question is one that nobody who is
prominent in American politics in a
of power right now is actually asking
and certainly not one that the media is
giving attention paying attention to
which is is it sustainable to have an
economy based on infinite indefinite
growth on a planet that at some point is
going to reach the limit of its
resources and by the way what are we
going to do to our environment if we
actually strip the planet of all of
those resources and burn them and
consume them and whatever else that's
the real question it's almost completely
ignored by both parties and in the same
way you know the size of the deficit
it's a very amateurish thing to look at
the size of the deficit doesn't tell us
that much the real question is why is
the deficit going up if it's going up is
the deficit going up because of
inflation is the deficit going up
because we're financing health care and
education which are very good for a lot
of people and stimulative to the economy
or is the deficit going up to pay for
the military industrial complex and you
know foreign military entanglements and
tax cuts for the rich which are
stimulative to the very few people that
are getting the cash in their pockets
but not by and large great for the
economy these talking points on economic
issues almost always fall completely
short of really informing anyone not
even about what the answers are they are
asking the wrong questions they are
predicated on a limited if not
completely wrong understanding of what
it is that we should be paying attention
to the GDP stuff is no surprise but of
course at the surface level Donald Trump
making promises he simply cannot cannot
keep and which his followers will almost
certainly not hold him accountable for